perhaps the most iconic scene from the
original John Wick film came via an
extended action sequence in the red
circle nightclub chapter 4 brings the
beat back the first part of that
sequence took place in the bath house
below the club scored by the Kalida song
think once the shootout progressed
upstairs to the dance floor the
soundtrack kicked into high gear as the
lay Castlevania song Led spirals took
over the song was named after the
swirling black and white imagery
displayed on the nightclub's LED screen
and composed for the film three movies
later the same needle drop gets a
reprise in John Wick chapter 4 in a
soundtrack filled with memorable songs
LED spirals once again stands out
pulling off the impressive feat of being
the only track to become a musical
highlight of multiple John Wick films